- [Narrator] Hello there.
Oh, hey, watch the road, watch the road.
I just wanted to tell
you a little fun fact.
Did you know that the guy who invented
cruise control couldn't drive?
He had a good excuse.
He was blind.
(playful music)
This is Ralph Teetor.
He was an amazing guy.
He lost his sight when he was a kid,
but it didn't slow him down.
He excelled in school
and became a respected
mechanical engineer.
He had a talent for visualizing
objects in his mind.
It led to amazing inventions such as
an early power lawnmower and a new version
of the fishing pole.
But his crowning achievement
is cruise control.
The story goes like this.
During World War II, the
speed limit was set to 35
to save on gas and tires.
Teetor's lawyer was driving him around
and kept having to brake to stay at 35
and that constant slowing
down and speeding up
started to make our intrepid
inventor feel a little carsick.
His blindness made him particularly
sensitive to the motion.
An inspiration struck.
Ralph came up with an
idea that would control
the speed of the car without the driver
having to touch the pedals.
Thus, the Speedostat was born.
Obviously, that name didn't catch on.
In 1958, the first car to use
Ralph's invention came out.
At first it was an 86
dollar luxury feature,
but over the years, cruise
control, as it came to be known,
has become a standard part of most cars.
So, the next time that you're
cruisin' down the road,
remember Ralph Teetor.
The genius, the engineer, the visionary.
(playful music)